hey John it's great hi Greg its John
hello rejects it's correct I'm trailer
for the new God Duns of the Galax is out
volume DOS
this time it's in Spanish from my
understanding Kurt Russell and all
Schwarzenegger are supposed to be in
this I'm joking
oh I wrestled Sylvester Stallone oh
really so let's let's watch this and
then we'll review it
darker
[Music]
whoa two types of things in the universe
those who dance and those who do not you
just need to find a woman who is
pathetic like you Groot I really like
the way this trailer was just done in
general because it starts off like oh
they're going for the darker thing the
darker approach I'm sure the film might
actually do well it's just a bunch of
very striking images at the same time
though like when they're doing that
Booga you know then when it started it
started feeling like there's more of a
weight in it as some type of darkness to
it but then it and the last like 30
seconds of the trailer just still shows
it's like no it's still gonna be a
really fun film you know yeah it's not
it's not only gonna be like this dark
transition it's still gonna be like the
same personalities that we really love
in a door yeah it's still gonna be very
present it hooks you with the intrigue
you know I think that song is a good
metaphor like here's that familiar thing
but in a slightly different way and then
they tease you with some cool you know
high-stakes looking action stuff is
really striking Syfy images especially
like that that circular thing with the
dude standing in it I appreciate
guardians of the galaxy a lot for really
jumping into sci-fi like wholeheartedly
and the whole space opera stuff and to
cap it off with the comedies perfect
just little star-lord the mask yeah I
think any cool space movie is when
someone pushes a button and the mask
comes off first time I saw that was lost
in space yeah I had that gun that you
could turn into a rifle bitching about
having has to put the gun together then
the mass comes on and as always that's
the first movie I can recall that was
able to pull that off pretty cool I'm
waiting for them to perfect that
technology for real imagine the first
few times they're probably like pincers
yeah and even though that scene with
Drax and star-lord doesn't reveal much
it still seems like Drax to become more
emotional less all about logic because
he's still an emotional being in the
first one you know having that same kind
of logic kind of dialog still got that
logical approach he's just you know
trying better to understand it yeah
probably capable of doing this yeah it's
very intelligent so he could at least
understand but ISA this is like it is
only really good role I can think of
that he's actually had yeah it's
definitely the most like notable yeah
it's because it's a real performance he
gets to put on yeah yeah when he gets to
play against he gets to be type and play
against type all at the same time which
is a lot of fun to me for this you know
he gets to be the big brute but also
kind of fun and intellectual and yondu
Michael Rooker Rooker recurred Darryl's
brother that's shot when he's walking
with rod because I believe in because
yondu doesn't really become part of the
Guardians but from my understanding of
the comics and I think in this one he's
supposed to become a part of the
Guardians and they even gave it more of
the comic look as we can see like he has
a much larger fin I take it that in this
scene
yondu like murder to punch people in
that are all just flying down now this
is a great [__] Charlie's a really
cool shot that's a great tease because
you know like he's walking side by side
with rocket racoon yondu has this
confident walk because it's amides it
seems apparent that he most likely just
killed all these people with his arrow
yeah I don't think he necessarily killed
all these people but I definitely want
to know what's what's going on that he's
not spooked by in any way it's a cool
teaser trailer because you know with all
the announcements that we got of like
her rustle as Chris Pratt's dad ego and
you know the fact that Sylvester
Stallone's gonna be in it as well
they're gonna have to character mantas
there's a lot of things to look forward
to it's gonna be new and fresh what I
love about this trailer was that is
still keeping a focus on the main
characters that we loved from the first
one the main characters and just all the
the space opera you know
bells and whistles that we love you hear
some really cool looking settings
there's a really striking sci-fi images
there's the comedy like this this
promises me everything that I
yeah let's go because see it's easy to
let go we're doing a seagull so let's
introduce all the new stuff and then it
but but I love how this trailer was like
no or we still want to show you that
where it's really still about keeping
the journey of these guardians together
I only saw guardians of the galaxy that
one time in the theater but for my
memory I believe that it ends on a note
where
yondu is talking about how he was
supposed to deliver a quill back to his
father eventually some type of contract
I think it implies that that quill is a
half the only half human he's not full
human I know we're gonna get more of
those answers I the ker Russell I
another making it more in a humanoid
form we can't just play a [__] planet
or something whatever it is in the
comics he's the same he's the character
from the first period is the same
character in the shared universe and Vin
Diesel's related a baby Groot in this ya
know it all winds up and then they're
part of the family
yeah next movie they're gonna actually
do muscle cars in space perfect
alright guys uh yeah I mean there'll be
more to talk about when they show us a
more full theatrical trailer but right
now this is a great tease the look looks
cooler I'm sure it's gonna have like a
little bit more of a dark tone which is
what sequels tend to do but for me it
seems like they're gonna have a good
balance still like I don't feel like
it's gonna get lost in the darkness yeah
this didn't make me concerned or give me
questions yeah yeah like like certain
teasers can like this just made me want
to see more so and I wonder how much
further this is taking place like it
seems like these these characters I've
grown together a lot as a team just from
this little bit of footage it seems like
they've gotten better at working
together the camaraderie has become
stronger and I saw him interested see
like what adventures that they go on
while we've been away and all that stuff
80 years and 80 years alright guys if
you're new to the channel subscribe
today become a reject John this guy
right here reasons to Jerry and Degas
Stubbs is something we don't promote any
important facebook.com slash bloom house
oh gosh
gotcha no catch no gotcha
this is fun I've never done this with
the camera before stop no